hey guys my name is Jess and I'm Dan
it's Wednesday the middle of the week so
make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the news coming for
the rest of the week today first up a
series of spin-off expansions has been
announced of a total war yet cuz he's
spinning Sega has revealed that the new
games will all live under a new brand
called a total war saga instead of
focusing on wider areas these smaller
scale games will build on previous
titles in the main series and center on
pivotal flash points within them in a
blog post
the first Total War saga games director
Jack lusted explained Total War saga
games will be the same mix of turn-based
campaign strategy real-time battle
tactics and hundreds if not thousands of
hours of gameplay as a regular total war
game but focus down on a distinct moment
sagas won't be revolutionary new titles
or introduced brand new eras they'll
follow one from previous total war games
and inhabit the same time period or at
the very least relate to it
luster suggests the game he's working on
will have a map size similar to total
water tiller but will be focused on a
smaller geographical area he also called
it another spiritual follow-up to total
war room - Justin I are currently in the
middle of a month-long fitness regime
and we're learning things about how
Pokemon go can be a gateway into
exercise fitness in VR and also how to
eat healthily stuff like chicken dinners
yeah that was a really drawn-out intro
into the fact that player unknowns
battlegrounds is getting an update
because if you're when you get chicken
dinner
very clever thank you a new update is
currently live on the game's public test
server that brings a bunch of small
improvements and bug fixes you can no
longer exit a vehicle that is blocked
all the way around and tire effects will
now change depending on the terrain your
vehicle is driving over UI performance
has also been tweaked and a new
Southeast Asia server has been added
unfortunately no hints at when the new
desert themed map and snowy arena will
be making their way to battlegrounds
player unknowns battlegrounds has so far
reached three million players on PC and
will make its way to Xbox one as a
console launch exclusive later this year
I think beating the both of glass in
destiny 1 is one of my fondest gaming
memories well it sounds like it could be
for another as destiny to director has
said they're making a raid unlike any
other it's like a vibrate to my speaking
to Mashable destiny twos director Luke
Smith teased raid5 as it's known right
now you'll be set in a place that quote
players believe is real and that
whatever form it takes will be unlike
the four that came before it destiny one
had four raids vault of glass crotas end
Kings fall and Roth of the Machine in
other destiny two and Luke Smith news
the latter has a build of the former on
his home console and soon you'll be able
to check out the game as well when the
beta launches on July 18 for ps4 and
July 19 for Xbox one well be there come
join our fireteam the Dan crowds
featuring Jess MacDonald it'll record
the Dan crowds that you'll be the only
one in it visors that is everything
we've got for you today do you remember
to check out our bits and pieces on
GameSpot including and that's new video
that we've shot with the two of us and
offer and any behind us it's a little
bit embarrassing and hopefully
entertaining for you you can also get
the game spot now app on iOS and Android
to get the top ten news stories of the
day delivered right to your phone and we
will see you guys tomorrow